utilisez des copeaux de bois pour
chauffer les maisons c'est l'idée
économique et écologique retenu par le
gouvernement dans le cadre du
développement des énergies renouvelables
les chaufferies au bois peuvent ainsi
alimenter bâtiments collectifs ou
résidences individuelles
illustration dans une ville de l'orne où
les 4500 habitants se chauffe
ainsi depuis deux ans reportage et
nièces monteux et cyril paquet utile vu
du bois pour se chauffer l'indignation
j'ai depuis déjà un petit bout de temps
mais là l'idée est un peu différente en
moyenne un quart du voix qui entre dans
une série n'est pas valorisé les écorces
d'arbres ou des copeaux sont des déchets
souvent bien encombrant les scieries et
maintenant en décharge ou le valais
brûle je crois que maintenant ça devient
interdit de brûler alors plutôt que de
polluer au fond ça court autant essayer
de valoriser ces déchets plusieurs
scieries entreposent leurs écorces dans
ce hangar tous les jours un camion vient
récupérer le futur combustible il sera
vidé à peine deux kilomètres plus loin
dans le bac d'entreposage de la
chaufferie
naturellement les arbres morts et leur
écorce relâche le dioxyde de carbone a
cumulé pendant leur croissance
autant les brûler même si là aussi ce
gaz est rejetée au moins on récupérera
de l'énergie un avantage par rapport au
pétrole qui lui une fois brûlé en voit
dans l'atmosphère des gaz jusque là
enfoui sous terre
de plus ici la combustion est étudié
pour être moins points de vente qu'avec
une cheminée d'un mystique
si on a
meilleure régulation deux à la fois des
débits d'air et des débits de bois dans
la chaudière ce qui permet
parfaitement contrôlé la combustion est
d'éliminer tout risque d'émission de
polluants
cette nouvelle installation a permis de
diminuer de 1200 tonnes par an les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le quartier elle chauffe 400 logements
hlm et ont hissé la terre à et
écologique et depuis peu est connu une
explosion du prix du gaz du fioul et des
différents combustibles
on est sûr d'une chose c'est que le bois
va rester stable puisque c'est maîtrisé
sur le plan national
à peine 350 chaufferie existe en france
du bois pour se chauffer ou même pour
fabriquer de l'électricité
seuls les papeteries le font aujourd'hui
les déchets sont récupérés brûlés et la
chaleur de la combustion transformée en
électricité
de quoi être partiellement autonome mais
en france cette énergie est sous
utilisée depuis la tempête le bois mort
de nos forêts pourtant ne manquent pas